welcome to this video forum around
twelve of the candidates and it's a
coverage for the game between lemon
Aronian and running Akram Nick the two
pre-tournament favourites by most
accounts for example I wrote a short
blog post for chess comm why estimated
the chances of the the players before
the tournament and there I gave Aronian
a 40 percent chance to qualify and
kramnik 20 percent so I had really much
thought that those two would be heavy in
the race on by the way I gave the vichy
5 percent for the for the qualifying
spot so I cannot claim to be much of a
fortune-teller I didn't really have any
clue that he would fight for the top
spot in and such impressive fashion so
let's look at this game there's still
lots of sporting relevance for the
tournament Kramnik is basically out of
it with no one it's no 1-1 even near the
bottom of the the table but Aronian with
this +1 score he is still only one point
behind honored and with the win ma'am it
might get tricky again of course a lot
needs to lose a game somewhere for it to
become exciting again but nevertheless
this is an interesting matchup ok
Aronian playing D for c4 nothing
surprising and he invites the nihms oh
I'm sorry he Dwight's the new zone which
he sometimes does it's not a given also
plays Knight f3 in this position again
Kramnik now surprisingly plays d5 the
classical Queens gambit with an early
night to f6 very often of course this
arises through 1.d4 d5 um and this is
not a very common guest in top-level
chess simply because the exchange
variation which aronia now is actually
playing the exchange variation is
considered to be quite comfortable for
white and there are not many black
players who want to
to this structure it is three noted that
he had Knight takes d5 is also means
that Kramnik in fact had played before
tried to transpose to the semi Terra
line like this this yet played before
for instance against Sevilla in last
year's candidates but okay 85 the
classical Queens gambit declined
exchange variation also known as the
cards but structure c6 Queen c2 yeah
there are some supplements about the
precise move orders but I don't want to
get too deep into that there should be
73 97 all this is very normal
note that black has not cathode yet this
is in fact important for the line that
he's now choosing here Iranian has some
a choice almost all players here played
the move Bishop d3 which is the most
flexible moving away as you need to put
it on d3 anyway this Bishop and it's not
much point in putting the knight on a
three for example and defining this
Knight position just yet he played
another move however not Bishop d3
played to move h3 which is very rare
it's only played like two or three times
out of I'm not sure 2000 games or
whatever that I had in the database a
threesome very rare move um what's the
point of it I guess h3 belongs to whites
typical setups it's only normally played
somewhat later for example just to show
what you what I mean Bishop e3 castles
93 okay this is the absolute main line
or you can also put the not only two but
just to show it here for example h3 is a
very popular move as it is after castles
9f8 h3 this is very often played to take
away an important square
the kingside preventing moves like
Knight g4 or Bishop g4 and yeah it's
very often a very good strengthening
move this can also be the idea
especially here h3 9f8 to play the
bishop back and actually have this
square available for it Aronian is
playing this move very very early but
it's not so important for the line that
kramnik is no choosing he plays the move
Knight to h5 this is a very well known
maneuver or setup in this in this line
for black that can also be employed
against Bishop to d3 for example this is
one of them
I guess best lines for black in the
exchange and it's very comparable here
if you look at this right here it's the
same position only now we have the pawn
on h3 not the bishop on d3 and white now
must be a bit careful with this move
order aronia played Knight to f3 Bishop
d3 is not really great because of Knight
F form the neat little trick on yeah and
to the bishop basically must retreat
which pretty much shows that Bishop b3
was was a failure so you need to go to
a3 there's not much not much else Knight
to b6 yeah this is played to get the
bishop out simply long castles again
Bishop b3 is met by Knight f4 and this
is not great so long castles this is
normal white castles long here and black
after he plays Knight f6 now this is not
necessary move you can also play Bishop
to e6 there's nothing wrong with that
black has two basic setups he can put
the knight back on f6 as Kramnik did or
he can play set up like this with g6
Knight back to g7 for example let's say
something like that
this can also be played with like
intending to play h5 for example or
maybe even f5 at the right moment f5
needs to be considered very carefully
though as it gives up the e5 square but
this is another setup that black can
play I liked ramnik since though he
played tonight f6 also controlling for
and now after this moves black is
castling long putting the knight on f6
has this has an additional idea and we
see this rather quickly like it's
playing ninety eight twenty six and this
is a very useful thing to remember in
those cards but structures pretty much
regardless if there was short castling
long cancelling here both sides have
casted long the knight on d6 usually is
very well posted now it does a number of
things we can put it on the bottom it
does a number of things
the knight is controlling a ton of
important squares it controlled c4 and
e4 which is very good it covers the
Queen side the important pawn on b7 that
is basically the backbone of the pawn
structure here it's a defense against
the possible b4 b5 the minority attack
that is normally played with both sides
having canceled short but even with long
castles that can be played and the
knight does an additional thing it
supports the idea to play Bishop f5 at
the right moment to exchange the
somewhat bad bishop iam yeah what is
White's plan in the structure it's
mostly associated with playing on the
Queen side this is also why he put the
King to a-1 in the corner so that at the
right moment you might be able to play
before me not exactly here but it can be
an idea and the other idea can be to use
a rook lift rook on the third-ranked
this was for example plate this rook
lift idea was for example plate and in
one of the classic games of this
structure played between Kasparov his
white and unders on the wolf Anderson
the
legendary Swedish Grandmaster um from
the late 80s I believe or early nineties
this game where Kasparov won a really
nice game against against unknown who
was always very tough to beat
yeah in this structure I believe that
white in this kind of structure has very
slight advantage he's um got a little
bit more space and somewhat more options
black but black is very solid this is
quite good to set up a belief for black
in the Queen's Gambit exchange it's not
everybody's cup of tea but it's
certainly very playable a very playable
option yeah Huronia put the knight to c5
he could have exchanged on b6 but this
does not really trouble black after the
recapture he's got a very compact pawn
structure the double pawn is not a
weakness of course how should white even
a ticket with in a meaningful way it
makes much more sense to put the knight
on c5 as Aronian did
yeah chronic played g6 yeah a very
normal move it supports this Bishop f5
ideas simply now aronia played aged form
there was quite surprised that I could
actually find a game that reached
exactly this position exactly this
position and in this game between
grandmasters vladislav iconic off and
the black player was barua
from from India on there was g4 played
which is also a common motif just to
control the f5 square and in this game
White was I think also slightly better
after h5 and Knight to e5 this is a very
important idea to remember too if you
after g4 the move h5 is very tempting
for black and quite often also quite
okay but you need to always consider
that we
a move like h5 you alter your pawn
structure on the kingside you have now
this structure which means that if a
knight appears on e5 which happened in
this game it is very tough for you to
play f6 to get rid of the knight as you
we can put it on the board of course put
blunder the house it basically means
that if you push a pawn like h5 you're
really influencing directly the center
this is very often not clear to players
that those pawn moves on the side of the
board can easily influence other areas
of the action here h5 is directly
related to the e5 square if you don't
play h5 let's say for example black
plays and nothing moves like let 78 it
doesn't make much sense I know but I
want to show you that after then 95
black can play f6 and does not have this
this tactical problem on g6 ok um
actually there might be another issue
him here there's a chance funkiness
quite funny this you don't want to have
so let's not play rook g8 for argument's
sake let's play rook c8 and now 95
I can play f6 and kick you back I will
just wanted to make this point about
strategy that this pawn moves on the
side of the board can easily influence
the center yeah chronic however he was
faced with another idea as Aronian
played the most h form he tried to
advance on the King side and this is
also related to the mentioned idea of
putting a knight only 5 if you imagine
this position without H pawns yeah just
for argument's sake let's say h4 and
like there's nothing just to show the
point this also fights 45s now f6 is
again answered by this Knight move now
h5 is move that fights 45 it is not
really h4 it's a move that fights for
the e5 square which is not directly
obvious probably but this is the idea
behind it
yeah Kramnik played action
read the move Bishop c8 after that and
after h5 he played g5 this was his idea
he didn't want this structure that I was
describing he could have played Bishop
instead of Bishop yet he could have
played Bishop a5 this wasn't a bad move
but I guess after this he was get on
maybe 95 first um maybe he was a bit
worried that after h5 here he would get
some some weaknesses on the kingside is
this looks like a very play with
position though and this is what he did
and this cannot be criticized really it
seems like a good option and even a bit
more ambitious option actually it in a
way asks why it's okay what are you
doing here on the Kings side really are
you going to take on age 7 or are you
going to do something else
if white does not take on age 7 he did
that he took on age 7 Aronian um yeah
what else are you doing if you play
nothing moves like that like might even
just play h6
and try to expand on the Kings side and
it's not clear what the move h5 really
has accomplished it seems pretty much a
given to me that you should take why
term white takes and what now what
exactly is Plex point yeah he played
reform and this is some an interesting
concept yes white going to go now with
the night yeah he went to aged form it's
not a happy square a bit here hmm it's
not clear this is really accomplishing
much like an no not they are sorry what
a bit too much falls into this the
smooth Queen f6 is an interesting idea
it turns out that black has this idea to
put a piece on a5 now especially at
night and there is f2 hanging so if
white covers this for example or that's
even the smoothness is even stronger I
just saw that yeah that's funny
yeah it basically comes to the point
that whiter what went well with night
age for Queen to f6 and g3 you basically
need to do that I don't really see
anything anything else what what what
can do there are there are some problems
with this Bishop p.m. do you play
something like that I'm going to
activate my pieces even further and and
another idea could be g3 from like if
you imagine a night here and then g3 the
night could easily land on e3 at the end
of all of that it's not not very helpful
g3 is okay it stabilizes Knight to c4
and now white voluntarily retreated the
bishop it was very difficult to do
anything else as at some point you will
give away the h5 pawn anyway you cannot
keep that pawn black and even sometimes
just play Queen g5 and take it
so we retreated voluntarily in a way and
of course prominent got the pawn back
rook e1 yeah why does toying with the
idea to play a form this is pretty much
the only pawn break left that he has
with the pawn on g4 so he has got the Q
inside at the Kings side basically I'm
basically paralyzed and only if is is
left but white certainly also like to do
is play Knight G to 2f form but that's
not easy to accomplish kramnik played
rook e8 if we now look at 92 for example
there is this response which makes a
look really active on h2 I mean
something like that is certainly
playable for white but it's not really
helping you much like can also all the
time get rid of this this Knight maybe
not hear of this Bishop sorry maybe not
exactly here maybe you need some prep to
do that maybe here not away and then
fine yeah it looks quite it looks quite
fine for Blanke and my book should be
about equal ya rupee - he played rukka
h8 Queen b3 er tried to tickle a bit
here of the square and black decided oh
sorry this was too quick Aronian played
before really doing something in the
center but chrome dick has a fine
response played b6 and now Knight a4 was
played and I think this is actually a
mistake and a pretty substantial one
aronia needed to take on d5 this is not
an easy move to play simply because it
implies some rather rather strange
tactics but it seems that you needed to
do that after after this caption I
looked at the following lines Knight a5
is the the critical move that asked the
various acts asks a very important
question where are you going to go now
with your queen what goes to before the
sloop takes d5 this rook is suddenly
joining the action and lands on a very
good square on d5 he is actually not
clear how wide is going to proceed
because there is a very important very
important idea Knight XB v coming
putting enormous pressure on deform the
Queen to c3 is probably the more testing
here it looks strange because you're
giving up a piece but this is actually a
quite interesting position that can get
very very sharp black has those somewhat
clumsy Knights at the moment something
like that for example can easily happen
this node is going to get lost with a
entirely unclear position like it's
already piece up so it's not like he's
blundering a piece like can also go here
which after the caption and see six
leads to a completely weird position
very hard to evaluate that um after this
capture as mentioned which is what
aronia probably should have done black
and also after this he can also just
recapture which is not bad at all
after that white has slight coordination
issues and probably should play
something like that to get the knight to
d3 and possibly to have form the problem
is he needed to do that what he did the
other alternative was this when Aronian
played in here it's quite funny because
after Bishop to e6 95 Bishop to c8
Knight back Bishop to a6 and you get the
picture they agreed on a draw okay this
is not a terribly big surprise
considering that kramnik has a really
rotten tournament and it's certainly not
really adverse to playing a draw and get
it over with
but there is one thing that needs to be
mentioned in this position here where he
played Bishop a6 and not just one time
but two times in this position he had a
very strong move available and this is
the move Knight to b5 and I'm quite
surprised that well maybe he just saw
the repetition and was glad that the
game is over but 95 is simply good for
black it's really as simple as that
the knight is attacking this weakness on
d4 and the white has no way to really
cover that it's quite remarkable that he
didn't he didn't go for it I mean it's
understandable considering the overall
situation in the tournament but black
would really have a great position here
without anything to vary just attack
this and what are you doing yeah white
what can take here
for example this stuff but look at this
hey this is hanging and there is b5
threatened this is in Hector an
immediate win white has simply no move
you cannot even pin the Queen as 93 wins
they exchange outright it's it's
completely terrible and yeah white
shouldn't take he can can try of yeah I
can't try to take here maybe you know
the idea being that now 94 Queen c4 is
not great for black you have forever
Knight to a5 and maybe here you did
underestimate something it's just an
intermediate attack on the Queen and if
it moves you're going to take with the
rook and now all of a sudden the rook is
activated here and puts so much pressure
on d4 that you're going to win the pawn
also note that right has two offside
Knights on a floor and h4 especially the
h4 Knight is doing nothing yet here
white will just lose the d4 pawn I
really it's it's like 95 is almost
winning it's it's very tough to see any
kind of defense um I mean I didn't find
any and the computer is just giving like
minus 1.5 so it's probably just a
flat-out win and it was I guess probably
overlooked by both players I don't know
I didn't see the the press conference
but I understand it from the
psychological point of view from Nick
was seeing the repetition and was
probably okay with that
as he cannot qualify any more and in any
case even with the win I guess erroneous
collector that he could get away with
the draw after this this mistake was was
made to to play here
hey this needed to take video on d5 yeah
a game that pretty much shows that both
players are not in excellent shape in
this in this tournament and it's pretty
clear that G Aronian maybe needed to to
do something to to catch Anand a draw is
not enough
okay he simply didn't get anywhere
commonly gets the tougher defender of
course and he was even quite lucky at
the end that Kramnik didn't go for 495
alright I hope you enjoyed the video
thanks for watching